[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting
i'm going to be talking about my recent
trip i mean so much happened on my trip
and on your trip that we've decided to
make it a separate episode separate
episodes there's not two parts they're
independent independent we can vacate
separately and then and then update each
other let's say that you know it wasn't
my idea for me to go first
and just before we got started you said
you know what
you should go first
and i was like and then i said i accept
this but i want credit
so i'm going to go first i know what i'm
going to say
i don't know what you're going to say
because i wasn't there so i'm i'm a bit
more interested in that it's funny
because
yesterday
uh well won't i've been back for two
days but yesterday was our first day
back in the studio following the trip
and stevie came into our office and as
as people do she said how was your trip
and of course i'm just sitting in there
with link and she's and i'm like um
well
i can't tell you because i'm i can't
tell link because i have to tell them on
ear biscuits it's like this you could
ask me to step out such a weird thing
and so then i was almost like well but
it is
so stevie you could listen to this
episode of ear biscuits to learn about
my trip but i i cannot tell you anything
right now oh she falls asleep to uh your
biscuits every night that's what she
told me
well it is boring at times especially
when you know us very well
um people do
do that though people will fall asleep
to podcast two ear biscuits
specifically
i feel like it's just our soothing drone
of conversation that uh
doesn't i mean it rarely gets so
enthusiastic that it's like an alarm
clock well i got something to get to
wake you up
i can encapsulate my trip in one visual
and that is me being squirted on
by a penis water gun
oh okay yeah just get ready there's more
where that came from show it to me uh i
do want to i've already talked about the
penis water gun but i do want to say you
know this is probably not an episode for
the children elizabeth
i don't know i don't know i know it's
not going to be crazy but what do you
mean you've already talked about the
penis water gun i just then oh i'm
saying usually if like they're like npr
would say
um
this episode if there are little ones
who listen they should not listen and i
said penis water gun before the
disclaimer so i just apologize for that
but there's more there's more than a
penis water gun that's coming so i don't
get to see it right now is what you're
telling like buy one i thought you said
a picture
what are you talking about a picture you
said i have a picture
um oh i said a mental picture oh crap it
was like a visual but i mean i'm sure
you can look one up on the internet and
just like a plastic penis that has a
trigger on it
and a woman in a golf cart squirted it
on me
a stranger have you even said where you
were i was key west i did say where i
was i already said i was increasing
maybe i'm having a listening problem
well
i having
i'm sitting i'm doing nothing but
listening uh yes
you have
almost had an intervention for this
several times but we just keep getting
by there's lots of kicking the count
down the road right so yeah uh only one
of them is key west key west is they've
never been there is the end of the line
my and i never been there as well i had
uh preconceived ideas about what key
west was i mean geographically this is
like the end of florida i did not know
that you can drive as my brother-in-law
and sister-in-law did because we were
with jesse's sister and her husband
uh
they had driven all the way from north
carolina to key west and once you hit
miami
you're still on a road
for
154 miles
is what the sign said after miami to get
to get to get to the end of the line at
key west
would you have known that i had no idea
that there's there's i mean hundreds of
connected bridges yeah i didn't know
there's one section that's a seven mile
bridge over the ocean it used to be like
the longest bridge in america
or the world or something but it's not
anymore it is still there though is
there like surf underneath you
waves are there waves
this is the ocean i did not cross the
bridge i flew there oh
yeah i flew from atlanta
to key west you can fly right into key
west it's one of those on a little plane
no
interestingly very small airport you
know talking like burbank style airport
just a few gates
but there's a lot of folks that want to
go to key west
so it was a normal sized plane
and
the island is two miles wide and four
miles long or four miles wide i don't
know the direction you don't direction
is not something that you're worried
about in key west first of all like
where's north and south nobody knows
and that's not what's on people's minds
i had i had these ideas about key west i
think one
real prominent sort of reputation is
that uh key west as as is like palm
springs is a place where gay men like to
go uh anecdotally i can uh confirm that
is the case older men uh my gay men of
all ages but okay but i do think that
the
um
most now first of all it's it but but
also all kinds of people i mean it
wasn't like
90 gay men it was also a lot of
just
men and women couples people just
of all ages but
it is a little bit older clientele well
my dad
went there a few weeks before you did so
i'm like okay i'm starting to develop
a clientele situation you get that gay
men and then you got my dad
who you know spends a lot of his life on
a golf cart going around myrtle beach so
if he's going to go to another locale
you've already mentioned a golf cart
yeah so i'm like okay this is starting
to add up for my dad maybe not for you
yeah well it's quite a melting pot
though most of the ingredients in that
melting pot are white
i will say that so it's a very white
melting pot miami is not white no no no
no um but but i'm saying people of all
walks of life but just like
mostly white
okay but i got to say i had a good i had
a good time it was a it was a good trip
as i will tell you tell me now we
originally now my my wife's sister and
her husband had been going to key west
for years
and always talking about how much fun
they have down there and how we've got
to join them
see i thought that was costa rica
am i crazy well you don't you have a
listening problem and it is probably
time for an intervention so you're
telling me that they never they have
been to costa rica and i have been to
costa rica with them and they didn't
want to start a business and move to
costa rica permanently uh that was a
separate it was a separate thing but it
existed and i heard it ha well since
then they moved on to key west which i i
never knew no these are they're
independent independent ventures and the
key west is a frequent
uh in fact they had already been to key
west this year like a month ago oh okay
right just a hop skip and a few states
down are they gay men
uh no no a heterosexual couple which are
they my dad that's about to say there's
there's a lot of that as well okay cool
i will say that i did get i i did one
night i wore my leopard print shorts and
i got a lot of compliments
so
the
they've been asking us to go down there
and you know how it is man i mean we
just we don't
a lot of our travel is related to work
and also over the past two years we
haven't traveled much at all
we had scheduled this trip
about a year ago when no one knew what
was going to happen with covet and like
where is it going to be
and we scheduled it for late october
right when uh it was actually his
birthday weekend
and i was like
i really doubt that this is actually
going to happen because who knows what
and then when delta the delta wave
started happening i was like oh no this
is there's no way we're going to do this
yeah and then in talking to science mike
he was like well actually
in places like florida
the delta wave is going to hit so hard
that it'll be in it'll will have receded
significantly by that point and it'll
probably and it's exactly what happened
and especially in key west the numbers
were never significant in key west i
don't know something about an island
nation where a lot of people are outside
you know it actually is a nation it's
the when you get off of the plane
the airport says welcome to the repub
the conch republic like conquer like a
conch show
because can they say that they
there are no rules at this place
you know the whole what stays in vegas
what happens in vegas stays in vegas
what happens on an island stays on an
island and i am convinced that even if
you can get there be a bridge right eat
i think that there is a deeply ingrained
like thousands like millennia
ingrained in humans that like hey
we're at this island we can do whatever
we want to
and what we do on this island listen as
long as we don't talk about it to
anybody else no one's ever going to find
out about right
now modern life has complicated that
because of the bridge but i do get
subconsciously
i mean it it's of a size that you feel
like you could see all of it in a day
or is it bigger than that well two by
four miles i mean well okay yeah it's
mostly there's like a main strip in the
middle which is
you know bars restaurants shops
and then everything around that is
a bunch of houses very very uh
i would say like a charleston meets uh
new orleans vibe in terms of like the
architecture like these
beautiful old southern houses that are
like the they i mean a lot of the
properties you know like in beaufort
there's in both of north carolina
there's like down by the beach those old
wooden homes not on colors
not on stuff that's strange i mean with
the amount of hurricanes that come
through and the thing that i was
thinking the whole time is i was
actually having trouble
like enjoying it
knowing that oh sea level is rising and
what it was this weird thing that was
happening to me i was like oh this is
beautiful but is it going to be here in
100 years it's gonna be like venice
don't get attached um because it
literally feels like because it's the
truth that this place is just above sea
level
and all the sand
is brought in from the bahamas there's
no sand
it's um you might picture like this like
caribbean island with a bunch of white
sand well all the white sand is brought
in from the bahamas and it is actually
like crushed coral
is what the actual surface of the the
sand is but most of it like as you go
around the island
the perimeter of the island is like
concrete
like a wall basically at some point they
were like we got to stop this water
because i'm sure every time a big storm
comes in the whole place gets flooded
um
but that didn't take away from the vibe
i mean this was we didn't go to the
beach
we went to the beach to like eat at like
some restaurants that are like right on
the water but there was no like hey
going to the going into the ocean for a
dip huh um but the specific weekend that
we were there
was
so but just just so you know
i made the decision that i felt like
this was a responsible decision in light
of where the numbers are at the fact
that i'm vaccinated and the fact that we
were going to be outside most of the
time
so
just to kind of give you give you that
piece of it and uh
but the specific weekend which again was
predetermined over like a year ago
because of ashley's birthday
happened to coincide with something
called fantasy fest
fantasy fest and
i don't know the history of fantasy fest
let me guess what this might be
but i mean so people go there in order
to
uh
i don't know just let it all hang out it
doesn't seem like it would be that
simple literally seems like key west is
just a place to ha that is a fantasy
festival i what about this weekend is
different i think it's just more of the
same okay now
how do i put this
during fantasy fest and according to
chris and ashley
brother-in-law and sister-in-law
this was an unusual amount of the things
that we saw because of fantasy fest
they're like this is not normal okay so
the fantasy did up its ante
how but during fantasy fest
a s
a light dusting of glitter on the
breasts is considered a shirt oh
okay
can i just say that a light dusting
glitter dusting of glitter now you can
get a full paint job
you can get just glitter
and there are multiple stands
okay what we would do the typical night
would be
going out to eat first of all
great food i mean
really really really good food like i
did not have a bad meal i was like bang
i mean chris and actually
i've been there down there and they know
the good spot so they were taking us to
the good spots
but that goes a long way man are you
sitting there dinner eating a really
good meal and you look over and there's
somebody wearing glitter for a shirt
well yes really
really you're dining
you've been seated at a table yeah this
is not like order at the counter and
then put your number at the table this
is oh this is fine dining this is
smoking or not and by the way
with with very few exceptions maybe one
exception we ate outside the whole time
no sure we did outdoor dining no shoes
so we're like no service unless you
haven't eating on the sidewalk and
many of the
like so when you're on the main drag
duval street which is like several
blocks
and it kind of has like you know the
main drag and like
like bourbon street or there's a number
of places in america that have this kind
of vibe public drinking yes and
even though technically public drinking
is not allowed no one's following i also
think being topless except for glitter
is technically illegal but the cops are
not having a problem with it it's the
conch republic but
conch i think conch
many of the restaurants and bars had a
bar on the perimeter of the restaurant
facing out so everybody would sit
looking at the sidewalk and the thing
that i noticed is that
there were a number of facilities that
okay this bar is a gay bar and there's a
drag show right
this bar is a gay bar and this is a drag
show but this bar is a bunch of old
heterosexual people
you know and it would be like right next
to each other and we were just going
everywhere but the bars that were there
was like these older couples sitting
there on the benches looking out and
they would just both be like
not talking to each other yeah and a
pair of boobies would go by and they
would just both watch them and then they
would talk to each other about them i i
sat there and watched the boobies pass
and then the people talk about it so
there were that many people just walking
around with their boobies flapping out
boob-looping it up with
just glitter or body paint
more were they were the nipples painted
or like really glitter specific depends
on the person man wow and what's the
what was the bottoms like are we talking
bikini bottoms okay well let me get to
that in one second because i'm not done
with the boobies yet don't yeah don't
don't leave the boobs until you're
you've fully explored them um
this is something that jessie pointed
out and and i have to agree how pointy
was it uh well i think that's my point
not in many cases not very oh and she
was like
there is a big body positivity thing
happening in key west
it isn't like somebody's like i have
what is considered to be the nicest rack
perfect body that would be an instagram
model
it was like
i have a body and i and i have boobs and
you're going to see them and i'm proud
of that and it was just like it was just
there was something
kind of beautiful about just the level
of freedom that people just walked
around with and again according to the
experts this is not every single day
this is fantasy fantasy fest and then up
to halloween is what i've been told
where this is really concentrated but
there's stands right like
you're walking down the street and then
there'll just be a woman sitting in a
chair
completely topless like pre-glitter and
then there's like another woman with
like an airbrush thing and she's going
in and doing the thing like it's like
going in like there's like a kid getting
face paint at the fair this is a topless
woman getting glitter or paint
on the street
and then there's like another woman just
standing there topless in line waiting
to go she's already taken ready to go
yes
interesting oh are there kids walking
around oglin at this uh
very few and the ones that were i was
like this is okay
not trying to be judgmental here but
i don't know if this is appropriate for
children they probably get over it
quickly enough i mean i mean most people
have breastfed
so and putting a little glitter on there
shouldn't ruin anything i hate glitter
until today man
change your view on glitter you asked
about the bottoms you didn't ask about
the men now that's where the bottoms
really come into play
yeah i don't really care about men's
boobies um tell me about the men scared
about the men's bottoms
no not really well i'm going to tell you
about them because it okay
very common
for
a man to be
in nothing but a g string
and when i say a g string like in the
back it's so small that until you get
close you just think he's naked nakey
you're speaking rihanna yeah and he
didn't there was one and then there's a
few guys who go the extra mile and have
that situation
but when you turn to the front
they have a one guy had a stocking that
was just around his junk that went all
the way down to the ground and like
dragged and i think he had a santa hat
on that's not what drag is no
no it was oh you know that he was
literally had something dragging okay so
that's a that's a chili peppers tube
sock taken to an extreme and if you can
step on it then you're gonna lose your
sock pretty well it didn't drag all the
time and so there's a lot and so
sometimes it's like a couple so there's
a
a man who's dressed like that
okay now it might be like a group of
guys who are presumably
gay and who who are dressed like that
but then also there's like this is an
old man and his wife and he's dressed
like that and she's dressed with the
glitter boobs and then sometimes there's
glitter boobs and then the husband just
has on like a golf shirt and he's not
participating it's like dressing up for
halloween sometimes you go in together
and sometimes only one person
participates this is intriguing it's so
fascinating a couple of questions i'm
ready to answer have you did you see any
topless glittified boobed women
who you could tell they were just
learning the ropes that they you know
they were kind no they weren't you mean
like the glitter had a spotty pattern
what do you mean no that they weren't
home
they were trying it for the first time
like for me and the tube suck i would i
like the idea
of of walking around in nothing but a
tube sock
i do
i sincerely am intrigued by that i would
like to experience that i think there's
a discount on tickets to key west um i'm
gonna dog-ear this conversation for when
i tell you about my vacation and some
things that i learned about
my own nudity
oh well so we'll come back to that but
no i'll answer your question i'm
intrigued but you know is there someone
who's like someone who goes to key west
did you think about wearing a tube sock
did jessie think about going topless was
there a conversation here and if she
would have gone topless it would have
been i there was a discussion
okay so i want to know about that and i
want to know
if she were to go topless there's an
adjustment period of okay i am going to
put my shoulders back and i'm going to
own i think you have to walk down the
side streets first because there's a lot
did you notice anything about it no i
didn't notice it at all i think people
have practiced
you know that's weird to me it's like
where did they practice you didn't go on
the side streets how do people work up
to being totally topless well i think
you're confused about something the venn
diagram between people who are
uncomfortable being naked and people who
are got glitter on their boobs walking
down the street in key west like
just two distinct circles that look like
a pair of boobs
you know what i'm saying that's the venn
diagram
and but they know what i like to do to
boobs you like to push them together i
understand that but the circles never
cross they don't they just get boobs
just get they turn into ovals they never
cross
no one was uncomfortable and that was a
beautiful thing now
there were people
again most of the the average age of the
people walking around we're talking 40
and so there's a lot of people over 40.
so that means that
there were there was the occasional
younger
you know less gravity affected
women uh just
that would they drew a lot of attention
and i'm talking like one out of ten
would be like oh this is just this is a
young woman who's she's doing the
glitter boob thing or maybe she's just
got fish lots of just just fishing that
nothing under it that's another thing i
i could go on forever about this but i
do want to talk about other things he
was caught by a troller or something
yeah and there well there's a lot of
fishing there's a big fishing industry
down there and one of the things that
would happen then is that people lock on
to those
there's a lot of is that is this double
standard is it boggling ogling ogling
and there's a couple there's a couple
times where that made me feel a little
uncomfortable where
i would be like kind of walking
and i would be behind somebody like oh
this okay this is a younger lady who's
obviously i can tell by the way people
are looking at her that she must be on
display and like the dudes would just
stop and most everybody is intoxicated
so there's just like this
open mouth open mouth just following the
boobs the whole time i was like come on
man chill out you're on an island uh but
last thing i'll say about this before i
move on to other things is there there
was a discussion not a realistic
discussion jesse wasn't about to do this
but she did say one night when we were
just the two of us were walking around
uh so we had gone out to to uh just the
two of us every we were spending uh most
of the time with chris and actually
there's one night where he just kind of
went out on her own yeah that's the time
and side street she was like what would
you she said what would you do
if i were to tell you that i want to go
and get my boobs painted
and walk around like this and i would be
like and i said um
i think i would probably advise against
it hmm
okay she said well first of all i would
never do it because i just can't i
there's two there's more than a seven
mile bridge between
her and her version of jesse that would
walk around topless at key west right
it's just not who she is yet it's not
who she is right now
but
um
i said
well honestly it would
oh here's another thing speaking of venn
diagrams the venn diagram of
mythical beasts and people who vacation
at key west there's not a lot of
crossover there either which was a
beautiful thing that's nice so i mean
there's minimal recognition no pictures
of you and just a sock
yeah floating around yeah
the people who've chosen to be
entertained by key west like they don't
need anything else they don't need
internet stuff man they don't need good
mythical morning they need a couple of
doofuses eating weird stuff on the
internet they got i mean you should go
there and you'll see yeah they've got
glitter it seems like that's pretty much
enough because the thing i told her i
was like i think the thing i would be
most concerned about is
like a picture of us getting taken
like i wouldn't if you really wanted to
do that and it would be and you wanted
it to be your thing i'd be like more
power to you
but she was like so you're telling me
that if there was no way anyone like
none of your fans none of our family no
one would find out you would you would
be like cool i'd be like yeah it'd be
fun it'd be cool
she would never do it and i wouldn't
expect her to do it and i would never
pressure to do it it's just there's a
certain mentality
that leads to that i don't know what it
is i don't know what path life path
leads to glitter boobs at key west but
there's quite a few people who get to it
it's freeing man they all seem very
happy and i'm intrigued
uh okay i got more to talk about we do
want to take a second um to tell you
about black friday is that coming up
already it is coming up yeah okay if you
want to be the first to know when our
sale goes live uh all you got to do is
sign up for our email and text
notifications at mythical.com i i'm i'm
trying to fight off a burp while i just
appraise it did it sound like it yeah it
did it's not like you should've released
it like i was about to
burp if you sign up now
uh you'll get a code for 10 off your
first order and then you get you get a
little text notification little email
we'll we'll do it tastefully you know
key west style
black friday mythical.com get ready for
it text email before i move on to other
things just to establish
i really really really really like boost
oh yes
okay
and uh
i wow i plan to go back not because of
the gl again it does
i'm still a little surprised by that no
i don't know here's the thing you know
how i describe it because like no i
didn't love bourbon street i don't like
i don't like those the party streets and
the bars and like the people
wretching into the
the the culverts there wasn't a whole
lot i didn't see any wretching i did see
like i mean just a pile of vomit
something did the glitter boobs cover a
world of your no
taste i want to explain i also want to
say that it wasn't just like you jimmy
buffet every time we're going out it's
just like glitter glue glitter booze
glitter boobs and that's the only thing
you're thinking about you've seen one
set of glitter boobs you've seen them
all kinda
and but there's there's live music
there's a bunch of people playing like
uh
a lot of people playing country music
um
and
the architecture of the whole place i'm
saying like during the day we ride our
bikes around i'm reading between the
lines but you haven't talked about being
inebriated the whole time so that would
help
was it clear was i inebriated the whole
time or if i haven't talked about any
being inebriated the whole time we've
been doing this podcast
a
is that a factor in your in your
enjoyment like island life you know
i stepped on a pup top well i didn't i
mean
i didn't drink every single night
because
if when i drink when i drink every
single night multiple nights in a row i
start getting like
psoriasis popping up on my face and
stuff so i have to kind of like watch
that
uh and it
honestly walking around i know cindy
loper but i get it with a few
drinks or no drinks at all wasn't that i
just don't i don't do that i don't i
don't i don't get like oh man that guy's
not going to make it home drunk this is
just a sober assessment go ahead i'm
talking about the island itself the
island has been there for hundreds of
years the arc i love it's my favorite
type of house like i mean this is where
like ernest hemingway had a house
uh and that you can tour this is where
harry truman had his little white house
that he would go to which was like this
beautiful piece of property that he
would go to convalesce from being sick
of different things and there's all
these historic houses
and then you just take a you get off of
the main drag and you and there's these
beautiful beach houses that again it's
all these things have been there for a
very long time every single building
every single home is very very old and
everything just has so much character
and then like it's that classic like
caribbean vegetation where there's just
so much plant life everywhere and you
just feel like i could go down this
little alley and there'll be like a
weird house here in a weird house nooks
and crannies i've talked about how much
i love new york city and london because
of the nooks and crannies yeah the
island version of nooks and crannies is
key west and so the vibe i kept saying
it over and over again the first night i
was like i love the vibe and i hadn't
seen a pair of titties yet
i was just like i love the vibe of this
not even one peeking around the corner
nothing
and um
and jesse was like oh well i knew i knew
you'd love this place because of the way
that it she's never been there but just
the way it had been described and of
course i love to eat and i love good
food and we started off right after i
got off the plane it started with a
really good meal
so and the company was great we had a
great time hanging out with chris and
actually hadn't seen them you know in a
while it hadn't been just the four of us
hanging out in a while so my sober
assessment of key west is that
yes it is for a if you if you're gonna
lean into the partying that's a certain
personality that's not me i i'm a people
watcher so i'm going to go have a good
meal have a few cocktails and then i'm
going to walk up and down the street and
we're just going to talk about it
there is a little bit of an element of
like feeling like this isn't who we are
like we're a little bit separated from
this it's kind of like going to a zoo
and just watching you know what i'm
saying yeah
there's this sort of sense of separation
from it and hopefully not i don't think
judgment but it's just like this we're
not going to do that we're not going to
break it out i'm not going to wear a
g-string she's not gonna put the glitter
boobs on but we had a great time
um it's a beautiful place
and
best
explored on bike
okay you don't really want a golf cart
there's lots of golf carts but chris and
ashley are really into the bicycles now
they had driven down with bicycles on
top of their car on top of the car and
then we got they got nice bikes like
chris has this i don't know how much it
cost it's a really nice not an e-bike is
it it's not an e-bike but it it kind of
has that vibe it's got like a button on
the
handlebar to lower and raise the seat
while you're going there's four
different modes
it's a beautiful like carbon fiber bike
it's awesome and they have a big seat is
it a street bike it has a mountain bike
oh it's got a big seat you got you you
got to be comfortable okay and uh then
ashley has a dropper post by the way
okay i don't know about the bike terms
ashley has very very useful in mountain
biking like one of these uh going on a
key west adventure i know not why you
need it she has
your size differently a very
you know
i don't want to say uh pb herman but you
know what i'm saying like one of those
bikes that's got the wheel covers and
it's painted and it's got like a design
on it and it's kind of it's like it's a
woman's bike it's funny that i've never
seen those type of bikes
on top of a car you know when bikes are
on top of a car and they're facing the
same direction as the car yeah that
these people are serious about their
bikes yeah and then when you look up at
the particular bike you don't expect to
see a pee-wee hermit bike but here we
are but you mean you can be serious but
you know what i'm saying like a beach
it's like like a really nice top of the
cruiser yeah i guess but like painted in
like it was like an aqua with like a
there's like flowers or something i
don't know it's a
it's another
this is an investment these are
different types of investments yeah yeah
but both they're into the bikes you had
to rent bikes to tag along i guess chris
had handled it he had the bikes rented
and locked up at our hotel ready to go
they were very excited about the bike
exploration of the island now i don't
know if you've met my wife i don't know
that i've ever seen her on a bike i will
say that well
if you if you haven't met jesse on a
bike you haven't really met jesse
so
you know she did not fall and there was
a couple of moments there was a very a
couple of very close moments and of
course i know exactly how the
joking went like the this you know you
were trying to set up the fact that like
everybody get ready and then she
probably got a little angry with your
ribbing well
and then she got on the bike and there
was no hiding here's the thing
and i don't advise this and i'm not
necessarily proud of it but
we didn't wear helmets because helmets
do not exist in key west like
i think it might be against the law to
wear helmets in key west on when when on
bike maybe a shirt too yeah and so i
wasn't again i don't recommend it but i
take my own responsibility for my own
life and when in key west i don't wear a
helmet when a bike and also you get
dressed up to go to dinner
and for jessie that means dress in heels
oh now ashley has some like technique
for like she gets her she gets her heels
like
um like here's the pedal and then here's
the high heel and she like grips it like
a claw that's what how cowboy boots were
originally designed to go in a stirrup
that same way yeah well she and she's
got it figured out but
jesse had not figured this out and also
the thing about jesse is um
both jesse and i
tend to be rule followers
jesse tends to be maybe
maybe a little bit more of a rule
follower than me when i'm on a bike i'm
like i know that the traffic laws
technically apply to me but i'm on an
island in this key west and who cares
and so you there's a i'm not going to
stop at the stop sign if i don't need to
and hey this is a red light but nobody's
coming now
and chris and ashley and i are all on
the same page there's a lot of like
coming up to a light and seeing that
nobody's coming and just going through
it there's nobody nobody no cars right
but jesse would get
she would get mad when we got to a light
and we just kept going it led to some
fights right and then she was also like
i'm not comfortable on the bus she
weren't there for the fight because she
was still back at the red light and
she's like i'm not comfortable if we're
gonna drive
to dinner and i'm gonna have a couple of
cocktails i'm not comfortable on the
bike to begin with and then you want me
to drive back in my dress in my heels
after a couple of cocktails without a
helmet she had a point she's gonna have
to take the dress off put on some
glitter to get back home uh so what we
should get there we ended up modifying
the bike plan for
we ended up modifying the bike yeah we
created a flotilla of bikes it was more
like a car
we put her in a wagon like one of those
we did talk about renting the golf cart
because the golf carts the golf carts
are so great i haven't seen your dads
down in myrtle beach but like the
picture the belch life but like is his
uh his can his fit six people uh no like
two rows and then one face in the back
no his his his doesn't have that a
second row
most of the ones in key west have
capacity for six or as many as can hold
on
plus very loud speakers which is another
thing yeah he's got that you gotta and
chris and ashley were on they were ready
for this they had a they have a speaker
that actually puts in the front of her
bike and they have a playlist
that's got i mean
it goes everywhere
but it goes everywhere with us and we
bring the music
to where everyone is
they do they have sort of like a latin
flare to the music
yeah i mean toyota like
you know like pit bull is where we're
kind of is like a is a
pit bull and everything surrounding
pitbull chris and ashley they can pump
some people
like i i can't see you and jessie
the funny thing is about volitionally i
have a i don't know what it comes from
but
i have a
i don't like to impose myself in places
right
i don't know what it is a lot of tall
guys have this thing we're like we're a
little bit hunched and we're trying to
make ourselves a little bit smaller we
don't like to draw attention to
ourselves so the idea of having a
speaker
that's bringing the party wherever we go
now first of all very common down there
but it that took a little bit of an
adjustment but eventually i just
realized that we would go by people and
everybody would be like
immediately begin dancing to it oh you
were like
and i was like we are doing the right
thing they've got this figured out yeah
they've done the reconnaissance but we
did not have a pirate ship
there was a pirate ship
one the second night i didn't expect you
to we're walking up and down and then
all of a sudden
hear the loudest music possible getting
closer to us and then i look and there
is a float that is a
pirate ship like a parade float like a
parade float but a pirate ship that goes
all the way down to the ground like a
low rider you couldn't even see the
wheels it looked like a pirate ship just
sliding down the road and then it has
the masts of the ship are basically
stripper poles let's just be honest
perfect and
uh i'm showing i'm showing you a video
of that right now you'll have to watch
the video version link for you to see
this because i filmed it we actually
followed it
and there's just this old dude
he's the only one up there dancing and
there's several old couples who were
back in the back kind of driving it and
the funny thing is is they went past and
chris was like that might be the chamber
of commerce like he wasn't joking
you know what i'm saying like that's
what we're dealing with could you could
you get on board and do a dance we
thought about it is that what was going
to happen later in the every stop like
more women got on eventually oh
uh and i mean let me see fantasy land
i'm talking fantasy fest i'm talking
about like a 65 year old man
where the ship's wheel is how he's
controlling this thing damn he was
really staring with that yes
and there's all these people in the back
who are in the age range and they are
blaring
[ __ ]
as loud as you possibly can imagine and
there's this like old guy who's just
like dancing to it i'm just like this is
and everybody is stopping and filming it
because it's so awesome yeah we are
pirates
that's what it stands for
okay so we got through the bike thing
but then we experienced the the test of
every marriage and that is
uh double kayaking oh god yes it is
that's it isn't it it is like i remember
kevin talking about his honeymoon to new
zealand and they not only they they
almost died on a double kayak
because they were about to kill each
other if you want to know if your
marriage is going to last
rent a double kayak and go on a kayak
tour
so the way you know it doesn't last is
you kill each other we've done this
before we did it in hawaii and uh and
then now we we did it in key west
and we were going to go through the
mangroves now first of all
there's this beautiful
mangrove these are trees that grow in
the ocean they're the ones that are like
they're on these islands but they're
kind of in the ocean as well and they
shoot these roots down and just into the
water and pull up the water and they're
like a environmental barrier for all
kinds of stuff and it's also like a
nesting area for all these sharks and
nurse sharks and crabs and all this so
we went on like an eco tour also in the
everglades i think uh i think so i mean
mangroves are all over the world
in coastal locations but that sounds
cool though there was tunnels like these
mangrove tunnels and we would go through
the tunnels
uh because oh you know like these
channels these tide channels that you
could go through
and i was just thinking man
i remember in hawaii
where there was some tense moments
and
i i was like
i go in thinking i want my own kayak and
i want jesse to have her own kayak and
then we get in line with the other
people who are there and the woman is
like um
if you can please
if you have a partner please get into a
double kayak that is what we prefer
doing damn it
okay yeah and so we get into the it
increases the chances of of at least one
person being able to get you back from
wherever i get in i get in the kayak and
and i say uh i'm going to be in the back
you know and i'm like here's what just
as a reminder and the moment that i
begin talking like this it feels very
mansplaining to my wife but it's not of
course but well i mean i've got i've
been on kaya i've been on kayaks a lot
right
and so i'm just like so i'm gonna be
the i'm i'm the rudder i'll be the one
who turns us
you just be the motor and i'm gonna take
your lead you take the lead in terms of
the pace because i can see you you can't
see me and i just want you to naturally
just go right and left and when you need
to paddle i'll let you know and when you
can stop you can just stop and for a lot
of this you probably won't even need a
paddle
and i can immediately even though i
can't see your face i know that i've
already started this off on the wrong
foot but i'm just trying to establish
some kind of system
for us to enjoy and you sweeten the deal
by seeming like you're doing a favor
i could do this all on my own and i what
i learned
in a short period of time is that the
double kayak experience with your spouse
is a great analogy for marriage in
general because first of all you got to
stay in sync
you got to
you got to know your roles and i'm not
talking about like you know traditional
roles i'm just saying that like you're
dividing responsibilities in some way
that you've mutually agreed upon there
is communication that is important yeah
um and you give your wife a
stick so that she can bludgeon you with
it right
now
i have to say that i believe that my
marriage is significantly healthier than
our double kayak experience
no there was no she didn't hit me
uh
well i don't even believe that we cursed
at each other but there was a number of
times i was like jesse stop stop like i
told you you don't have to paddle
because i'm trying not to be the guy
who's yelling at his wife and we're in a
group so i'm kind of just just so she
can hear me like you could stop paddling
now
and then she's like well you're and then
she's like well you're not yeah but if
if i stop paddling we we we're hitting
this thing or we're doing it wrong we're
about to hit them she always thinks that
we're about to hit somebody it's like
i'm like no we're going to go next to
that person well it seemed like we were
going to ram them there was a lot there
was a lot of that we did get through it
we did get through it we literally got
through the the mangroves and we got
through without getting uh mad at each
other
uh got to know some people and that's
really cool i got some great video of us
kind of going through those tunnels
which you probably already have seen
did you think about putting the argument
on instagram because it's like it's one
thing to put the pictures but like i
think that's really where we're at as a
society we got to start
putting our [ __ ] on instagram uh no it
didn't i really like the like
instagram photo versus real life
i'm a fan of that
temper's expectations i didn't put any
of this on instagram i i did notice that
when i am out doing something like this
i'm actually thinking more about the
podcast than i am about my social media
which i whether that's strategic or not
yeah i get that i'm like i'm going to
take a video and i'm going to take it
landscape you know i'm like
all my video most of it is landscape
because i'm thinking about the
presentation on youtube on the video
version of ear biscuits well to take up
for us i do think that it
compartmentalizes it in a way that it
that's a lot less
it takes a lot less effort to just think
about something and shoot a little
something that you want for yourself
that you might share with people in this
context later than sharing something in
the moment and then you're drawn into
the comments
and the reaction to it and all of that
it's like i think it is a
it's not a it's not pure but it's a
better choice yeah and i i just i'm just
not i just the whole idea of like i'm
going to capture this this and this i'm
going to put it in like a photo dump i
just i just can't get there i don't know
if i ever will and that's fine it's fine
i want to tell you a really cool
thing that i brought i have a visual aid
short little show-and-tell i'm going to
show you
so one of the nights we're going up and
down
taking in all the sights
uh we also did like a little a self i
highly recommend this self-guided food
tour like during the middle of one of
the days where chris and actually oh
there's this great cuban place that does
a really great burger oh and there's
this place
on the water
they set up the tour chris and ashley no
they were like we're going to bike to
the places that we think we should get
things but it wasn't like it wasn't
there was no there was no itinerary set
by somebody else yeah yeah and so you
didn't download a pdf and the funny
thing is is i've done this two times in
the last month when shepard and i went
to the grove in la we did i was like
let's not just eat it one place let's
get a little thing at like four places
this self-guided food tour is i think it
might be my new thing
but we did this there we got this
lobster pizza and then this lobster roll
shout out to the guy
who worked at the lobster roll place who
was a huge mythical beast so there was
one and he's like dude i've been
watching you forever i have the mythical
shoes so like he's you know so there
were a few of the younger set that i
that i met that knew who we were
uh anyway i ate a bunch of stuff oh and
then key lime
so
i know i didn't know i'm from south
georgia and i didn't know that like key
limes are like like the florida keys
like it's the lime that comes from that
place and key lime pie is the thing down
there and there's all these key lime
shops and there's key lime pie on every
single dessert menu and like key lime
pancakes a key lime everything and i
love key limes
top three favorite desserts maybe number
one
are they smaller
well there's more floridian there's a
place where you can get a key lime pie
on a stick that's dipped in chocolate
and that was the end of the food tour
self-guided food tour i mean it doesn't
get any better than that i actually had
to call my mom after that because she
loves key lime pie oh were you crying a
little bit a little bit
but one night we're walking so good you
eat the sticks this is what it is on the
stick walking down the street
and
i see a guy selling
his art on the side of the street
and he's currently doing his art as well
and his pen and ink which i've
discovered this about myself in the past
12 to 18 months that i'm a huge pen and
ink art guy
i don't know what it is but key lime
goes with pen and a something about the
level of detail okay uh i've always been
into people just doing this incredible
detail in a relatively small space with
just a pen i also think you're just as
into realizing you're into something as
you are being into it we know which is a
double cool well no because i could
there's a number of different arts that
i ca you're right about that but i'm
saying there's something specific about
pen and ink that i was like oh i
actually am a huge fan of this you know
i do my the little thing where i do i
haven't done it in years but i do like
the little like mechanical drawings with
a pen and with pencil you've i haven't
done it in years but i do like these
little intricate little mechanical
drawings of like the system and the
pipes and the stuff i don't know if
you've even seen like buddy system
season one yeah yeah yeah i do that kind
of thing to kill time i don't do it
recently i haven't done it recently
and
so i see this guy doing this incredible
pen and ink and then he's got his prints
that he's selling and i start talking to
him i'm going to tell you about
daniel linehan
okay
line hand line hand with no d
and
this is a guy
who has set up now first of all we're
talking to him and like jesse's like oh
you're gonna love this and we start
going through his prints and
i'm like oh man this is oh i i'm gonna
leave with at least one of these
and
you know when he sells them for like 50
bucks a pop it's a print and i'll show
you the ones i got and you know
and
which is a great deal for a print on
something that's this detailed and
so
he begins kind of telling his story
and he's like you see you know the van
over there the sharpie van we're like
yeah we've been looking at it all week
it's like yeah i made that so let me
show you this sharpie van so like the
marker shark in 2016.
this guy took a van
oh wow and
hand drew
in sharpie and sharpie it's kind of hard
to see just how now different colors
like if you the closer you get like
there's incredible detail in every
single
panel and he okay and he did he started
drawing on his
this van
and and then he's like a full sleeve of
tattoo but it's a van not an arm but
listen to his story so i'm gonna read
because this is this is an article
from this is going to be great for
people to fall asleep too uh
fikeysnews.com oh florida keys news
[Laughter]
florida keys fl keys news doc
one of my favorite websites
and uh so this is his story because he
and what she what she ended up telling
me as i sat there and talked to him
right uh so this guy's and he's older
and so
he's probably about six he's probably
about 60 years old at this point okay
but what does he want to get to the part
where he says okay um
because he told me you can you use his
voice no because i can use an older an
article
it's just i'll use an older voice but
just as somebody who lives in florida
he's reading the paper okay linehan
recalls walking with a friend in fort
myers when they came upon a young woman
savage
i
i was hoping for it to be
lionhead recalls just a little more like
oh like this is
dramatic
linehan recalls walking with a friend in
fort myers when they came upon a young
woman savagely beating another young
woman
while a group of men stood guard to
ensure the assault wasn't interrupted
he said he intervened and managed to
separate the victim who had lost
consciousness from her assailant only to
be jumped by four men who beat him so
that he required hospitalization and was
left with permanent damage in his right
eye oh god
i don't regret it lionhead said my own
mother said
why did you help that girl it could have
been her or my daughter
that's what he said i guess that was his
answer
the day his this is the thing the day
his eye patch came off lionhead said he
went home and sketched the last supper
all in freehand in black ink he keeps a
print in his van along with a portfolio
of his drawings now this guy had not
drawn which is the thing that the
article the florida keys news they need
to work on their the back story but if
he had never
been an artist before that is a key he
had not drawn
in 30 years
oh and he has this near-death experience
he wakes up he takes off the eye patch
you can basically only see in one eye
and he sketches out this incredible
hand-drawn last supper picture and then
he just moves on and i'll show you the
ones that i ended up getting from him
the dude's a freaking hero
oh wow look at this oh this is upside
down
wormhole substation now
uh here's what i want to tell you about
this guy
he does not use any no reference
no ruler it's all completely freehand
like where this is in the middle of this
page is all that's this line right here
all this stuff is just completely
freehand and just with a pin and then
uh this is another one so let me just
let me explain this the wormhole station
for people
okay so it's some futuristic looking
um i mean there's
there's rail cars like subway cars
wrapping around this thing that kind of
looks like a
a space station
but it's very cushiony looking and
there's people yeah like weightless
astronauts like
tending to things and there's like
little
one-man
helicopter
things that are floating around
everywhere it's very fantastical very
fantasy land and they're all very very
different like
oh yeah this next one this one is this
one is an outdoor scene with
mountains and forest and it still has a
train but it's going across this
amazingly detailed
bridge from one tunnel on the right into
the other tunnel it's hard to
communicate how
long this takes
somebody and also he's the cool he's
talking about how he's like i don't look
at any other artist's work i don't i
don't because jesse was like do you have
a website he was like no i don't do
social media i got no website he's like
this is my website me
on duval street he said this is my
website yeah yeah yeah
like
he basically was like this guy has
detached yeah from
the internet
and is out there drawing this stuff on
the street and selling the prints this
is i mean i'm just this is the stuff
that i'm into i just love i'm going to
put both of these up in my office at the
house i thought this was for me no i
didn't get you any you can come into you
can come into my room anytime i really
like this one yeah but you're not into
you're i've never heard you say that
you're in a pen and ink you can you know
what you can take a picture of it look
at on your phone anytime you want can i
make a print of the print i know well i
would charge you 50 for that maybe 60 to
help with it it's mesmerizing it almost
makes me feel
relaxed but i got to say if you are down
there and there's a lot of things to see
like i said i mean glitter boobies are
one thing he is his own website
um but he's just living the life down
there drawing
these inc these incredible uh
i mean he was working on one that was a
playing card and it was a king and a
queen and he had fig he had done one and
he was doing the next one and we i saw
him for like three nights because i
first night i hung out for a little bit
and got his story and then
actually somebody too it was interesting
two different sets of people came up and
were big fans of the show while i was
buying this stuff and so he was like
well i finished my story but now i got
to hear yours and why these people are
coming up to you
well my website is a real website
and so then he wrote because he this man
only works with pen he wrote down rhett
and link on his palm on his pile and
then the next night he chases me down
he's like i saw he does go on the
internet just so you know he he gets on
the internet he just doesn't have his
own website well he does but that's it
there is a daniel linehan who is an
artist in texas not him different guy
who does have a website by the way screw
just a different guy not a pen and ink
guy so uh
he chases me down he said oh i checked
it out i love it
as a check it out i love it so uh shout
out to daniel linehan if you're in key
west go by there check out his art
support independent art about as
independent as you can get now i uh a
couple of closing stories
one of the things that i gotta go to key
west homie oh well
if you can ride a bike i mean my dad's
already been
i would love to go to key west with your
dad good lord that would be awesome so i
don't get a print and now you just
invited my dad to go after i just said i
want to go okay cool i get it so again
we got we need to have our own things
walking down the street as i did over
and over again and
i look like this right i'm a big guy and
i've got a beard and i've got hair like
this and there's a lot of drunk people
who would just say the first thing that
comes to their mind and at least two
people said
jesus
are you serious
yeah yeah right yeah and uh they weren't
they weren't it was not as an expletive
they thought i was jesus
and uh maybe mormon jesus i don't know
um you know like really really white
jesus
uh
so
that that was fun
and this is going in the con column
but the best thing happened that
happened was
lots of people dressed up like different
characters because they're going not
just glitter boobs and thongs but people
dressed up as characters because they're
getting ready for halloween
it's like a hat 10 days to halloween
let's get started
and there's a guy
clearly dressed as jack sparrow and he
was either
actually drunk
seemed very drunk or he was just a great
actor like johnny depp level
acting drunk okay but the what the way
he addressed me and what he said to me
makes me think that he was actually
drunk because he saw me from a distance
and came up to me and he was like
mimosa
jason mimosa
jason the most
i like the drink
and i mean that that is the perfect
thing for jack sparrow to say in modern
times but to you the thing is is he was
not joking he wasn't joking he had had a
few mimosas himself
and he is giving he has now given me my
alter ego i'm not jason mamoa i'm jason
mimosa man that's that's you know i'm
the
much more active i'm the wish.com
version of jason momoa now
by the time this airs you'll know
whether or not we pulled it off but as
soon as this guy called me jason mimosa
that was when you know jesse and chris
and ashley were like well you got your
halloween costume now
and uh we're like what are we gonna do
is jessie gonna be
a champagne glass and she's just with me
is her is she look like a brunch mom i
don't know how the costume is gonna come
together you'll know now it might be on
my instagram if i figure it out but
that was that was a highlight was being
called jason mimosa
yeah okay and then final story not has
nothing to do with key west but it is a
story
that was communicated to me while i was
in key west and it was the biggest laugh
that we got while we were in key west
and i do want to premise this with the
fact that we had a couple of cocktails
so you're in a completely sober state so
you can be the judge of how funny this
is i'm never in a completely silver
state right so chris no way to be
chris is uh he's got a guy who's working
on his house doing some kind of repair
and uh
he's
he's getting to talk to the guy and
somehow he ends up finding the guy ends
up saying i'm how old he was
60 65 something like that
and chris is like wow
you look really good for your age what's
your secret
and he leaned in
and said
with no sarcasm or irony at all he said
i eat [ __ ] every day
are you serious
what
yeah oh god so
hey did that really spoke to me
and it gives me something to live out of
youth huh yeah so a regular pasta
so if it's anecdotally
that is the the way to to keep that skin
looking young
the dude is not joking it's like it's
like a really it sounds like the kind of
thing like a fountain of youth a guy
would say is a joke but he was
i was like
every day then he laughed and chris was
like no he didn't and then
because he didn't laugh chris was like i
can't i don't know what the follow-up to
it was but i think it's oh so you're uh
you're a cat person when you're at
dinner in key west and you've had a few
cocktails and somebody tells that story
you laugh an embarrassing amount but it
doesn't matter because you're in key
west you know what i was a wonderful
thing i'm starting to pride myself on
being the person in public places that's
having the most fun
like there's nothing wrong with laughing
the loudest everybody just gets jealous
i love that
you're you're actively doing this uh it
happened it's happened a few times and
i'm like
it's great it's great knowing that
you're having the most fun at an
establishment
and everybody knows it well that's not
why you do it hey i'm about to say
what's the motivation is it
is it just i'm doing it to show off or
i'm doing it because i'm uninhibited
there's two two very different things
it's much better to be the laugher than
being the person judging the laugher
yeah nobody in key west is going to
judge you that's right and that's the
beautiful thing about it uh there are
places to laugh like that and there are
places not too anyway i do i recommend
key west uh sounds like it do do i have
it do i have is is it my rack in general
yeah
i don't think i can just give you the go
to key west right i mean that's you know
that's just not something that
everybody's in a position to do so you
may regret it uh but i do highly
recommend it while it's still
you know above water but i will say
completely unrelated
i had never read
this is my official wreck never read
anything from andy weir you know the guy
wrote the martian
i've seen the movie
but then he has this new book project
hail mary
and
i
i don't believe i could have read it
like physically read it i listened to it
the only reason i'm saying that is
because he is so
so technical and he gets into the
science in a lot of detail
or i think that my attention span i
would have had trouble sticking with it
but it was perfect
to listen to because i am interested in
all that stuff but great story i mean i
was like oh this is i this is this is
why everybody talks about how great this
is uh it kind of reminded me because you
talked about the three-body problem
which i think you recommended at one
point way back in the day but just like
a
sort of
futuristic interstellar
you know story that gets into some
really
interesting
scientific details but also just happens
to be a great story about
humanity and maybe things beyond
humanity you finished it oh yeah yeah i
definitely i finished it and was like
if you like andy weir you know he hasn't
written that that much stuff so it's
like if you like andy weir what else can
you read
and uh i'm trying to find some things
and so far i've not been satisfied okay
well but i think i might have to read
that three-body problem since you talked
about it might have to i'd listen to
that too if i were you for the same
reasons um okay yeah all right and we're
not weird all right next week i'm going
to talk to you about my
excapades escapades excavates my
escapades in big sur
in on the coastline of california with
my wife
so come on back y'all in the meantime
hashtag your biscuits be a part of the
conversation uh weigh in on key west and
any stuff that rhett talked about
please do bye-bye
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]